[Music]
for 75 years now
corporate profit over their total value
has been decreasing that means
corporations are really good at
accumulating money but increasingly
worse at deploying that money at making
money with money this is really serious
pharmaceutical companies don't know how
to make drugs they only know how to
acquire companies that do Google even is
no longer a technology company Google
became alphabet it's a holding company
Google's new business is buying and
selling technology companies they bought
a robot company now they sold the robot
company so they might as well be Goldman
Sachs or Merrill Lynch or somebody they
are a meta company now because they
don't know how to create value that's
because they're using a bankrupt method
they're using a thirteenth century
corporate operating system to run
digitally enabled businesses what I'm
arguing is that thirteenth century model
is obsolete it was based on going to
South America and enslaving people and
taking their precious metals it doesn't
work for a digital economy it doesn't
work for an economy where people are
buying and selling and trading and
making videos and exchanging value and
if you want to do well if you want to
actually make money you have a better
shot of it by creating circulating value
think eBay not Amazon think Bitcoin not
uber and you're slightly on the path
it's a peer-to-peer network economy that
we're moving into if you can conceive of
that if you can get yourself out of the
frame of mind where you want to get to
ring the bell on the Nasdaq Stock
Exchange you're not going to get to do
that I promise you you're not that's not
the way to go you don't want to sell
your business you want to run your
business and make money doing your
business and you have such a better
chance
becoming a true millionaire and doing it
in a way that's not taking value from
other people but is actually promoting
business activity on on a wider scale
and on a more distributed scale than was
possible back in the Middle Ages right
now most CEOs are selling off their best
businesses their cannibalizing their
most productive enterprises in order to
show short-term growth to shareholders
that's actually bad for the long-term
success of the business because without
successful revenue generating industries
it's hard for the business to keep going
they actually need revenue you need to
be selling something you need to make
money in an ongoing way I know that's
heresy I know that's that I know I get
it I get it I realize that's bizarre to
say it but they're the way to
communicate that to shareholders is to
say look you're going to start making
dividends dividends are okay you're
going to make money for owning my shares
of stock now what we have to do is start
looking at the tax code to stop
punishing revenue generating businesses
and instead start punishing ones that
don't generate revenue but just try to
grow the business at the expense of the
economy that's not hard to do it's we
have to increase the tax on capital
gains and decrease the text on dividends
this will encourage businesses to make
money rather than to just eat themselves
in order to show growth how do we help
people create value rather than suck it
out how do we help businesses and
neighborhoods circulate value rather
than take money off the table so you
look at a bank so all a bank has to do
and they just call it an experiment it's
not a new banking system don't worry
just a little experiment in a couple of
towns so normally a pizzeria wants to do
an expansion they come to the bank and
they say look we want to expand put in a
ladies restroom separate from the men's
we need $100,000 to do that the bank
will give them $100,000 eight percent
interest
and in 10 years you pay back your loan
but the bank should do instead is say
look Luigi we love your idea for an
expanded restaurant we'll give you
$50,000 toward that expansion if you can
raise $50,000 from your community
through crowdsourcing so what we're
going to do is put this film $50,000
aside for you and we're going to give
you this tool this app that we've
developed which will allow you to raise
money from your community what you do is
you ask your patron for $100 now and
then they can get a hundred and twenty
dollars of pizza at the expanded
restaurant so the customer now is making
20% back on their money which is better
than they're going to do in the stock
market or anywhere else they get $20
back you get to pay back half your half
your loan in interest but half your loan
in pizza which is cheaper to you than
capital we get as a bank we get your
proof of concept we can see that okay
your community really what does want to
support this and the community now gets
to invest not just in the S&P fund not
just in some mining company in the
Philippines but they get to invest in
their own Main Street they see their
restaurant expand they see the property
values go up they see their tax base get
better they see their public schools get
better and they see a business they
relate to a business now as community
members so now the bank is seen less as
the pure extractor of value from this
town and the exclusive purveyor of
capital and instead as the facilitator
of local economic activity now why is
that important because well if rushkoff
is right if Paquette E is right and the
and capitalism is itself about to
crumble under its own weight what is the
role of the bank going to be on the
ground can the bank establish itself as
something other than the pot of money
can the bank reposition itself as an
expert in how to facilitate local
commerce if they can do that then
there's a place for them in the digital
economy as well as the current one
another simple idea say you have a
supermarket chain you know and we all
know that supermarkets are being looked
at now is the extension of big Agri and
an unsustainable long distribution chain
of food everybody wants to go to the
local local and the Community Supported
Agriculture and grow their own stuff how
can the supermarket chain look like
something better than Walmart just this
big industrial wasteland well what if
they open their parking lot on weekends
to a farmers market you can charge for
spaces if you really want but more
importantly you just allow that activity
to happen you're seen as a partner in
that activity rather than as a
competitor that to that activity yes
people might start to favor buying
produce and an agricultural products
from that farmers market ok but maybe
the farmer's market does that better and
what do you do better you do packaged
goods you do long-distance stuff you do
cans you do frozen you do what a
supermarket does best this way you've
shown yourself really as able to
specialize in what you do and at the end
of the day when that farmers market is
done you take all the groceries you take
all the produce that wasn't sold by it a
discount from the local farmers and sell
it on your shelves Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday so again it's a simple way for
a supermarket to see its competitors not
as competitors at all but as partners in
food and then you will become the hub
the locus of this activity of this value
creation now it's a matter of seeing
this other activity less as a leak less
as a drain on your revenue and more as a
source of exchange as a source of value
creation because if your town is
bankrupt if your town has no way to
create value they're not going to be
good customers anyway Walmart Walmart is
right now closing stores because after
20 or 30 years of operation its
bankrupted its community
it doesn't let anyone else create value
and that doesn't work in the long run it
only works when you have a
scorched-earth flip this house approach
to your business but if you're not going
to sell your business if you want to
stay in your business you've got to find
ways for your customers to create and
retain some value otherwise they go away
but I get it this sounds like it sounds
like communism I know that but the thing
is it's the other one that's communism
it's the other one that's communism make
money for a living work for a living
this is cool to work for a living it
actually is fun and you have customers
and they want what you have and you sell
it to them for a profit so you take how
much does it cost you to make the thing
you add something to that and then sell
the thing to someone else and you end up
with more than you started with it's
just genius
you